I play Adina a very kind of unapologetic
out-and-proud
muslim lesbian artist she's kind of like
a controversial photographer and she's
just a really interesting character
because she's very she's very bold she's
very independent she's really confident
and we kind of see this a Muslim woman
in a way that we haven't before she was
like really in charge of her life her
choices and of her sexuality so it's
it's exciting it's a character I think
we haven't seen before and I'm a huge
pleasure for me to play is that Susan of
Marcos I want you to meet them I'm
supposed to have dinner with them
tomorrow night so maybe we could invite
them over or I'm sure you want me to be
there I know you've never introduced
anyone you were dating to Berens before
yes I'm sure
when you haven't seen a character like
that done before you're just really
worried about doing it right making sure
that everyone is going to be ultra
sensitive and have the best intentions
so that it doesn't feel like like you're
exploiting this character in any way and
those were my concerns but I think any
concern I had was put to rest once I
came on the team and like everyone on
the show is so wonderful and so nice and
it's so collaborative and we really just
got to flush her out in a collaborative
way and make her as interesting and I
think real as possible